on this episode I talk Italian ices
self-promotion up front in a video and
the Jets if I don't buy them who do I
buy you keep asking questions everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're
watching the askgaryvee show episode
number 23 a little fun fact about the
number 23 is a lot of people like that
number it's because there was a
basketball player that used to play his
name was Michael Jordan and everybody
liked him so much and thought he was so
great but not this guy
I hate Michael Jordan Brian asks should
I post articles on my blog and mention
on social or post natively on sites like
LinkedIn medium and Facebook or both
Brian great question and it's a loaded
question right because you probably
looked at the new garyvaynerchuk.com and
you probably realize that I'm doing a
mix right like you know you land on that
page and I've got the place for medium
posts and LinkedIn posts when you land
on it some of the posts to literally
link out to LinkedIn medium and then
obviously I have my own post and
actually Steve and I were just talking
did we put up the first post where it's
just for garyvaynerchuk.com got it so
that's there too and so what I think is
interesting about this question is most
people in the internet marketing world
want to keep telling you to do it on
your own site monetize your own traffic
it's yours
Facebook reach can't take be taken away
all this own it own it own it
the problem with own it own it own it is
when you're doing it on your own site
you're at the mercy of how much traffic
you're able to establish on your own
site and so for the 99.999% of you that
are watching this that don't have 4
million unique people coming to your
site every day every month the reality
is this place is like medium for example
I had a medium go extremely viral by you
know viral Azzam it did really well on
medium and right now it's sitting as
number six or seven on mediums top
stories where I've noticed that 950
people have clicked over read the
article because of that place and that's
950 people that I'm gonna guess 787 of
them
have never been heard of me before and
so too many people are worried about
monetizing them now posting on their
page versus using things like LinkedIn
and medium and notice I use those two
because they have viral loops LinkedIn
when articles go well it shows up in
pulse medium get sends out an email and
has the top stories so I like being in
places where there's viral loops that if
you put out a nice piece of content I
noticed a kid on Twitter today clean out
hey I'm number four on medium two spots
ahead of Gary Vee and then I looked at
his profile and he has 1400 Twitter
followers and that got me excited I'm
like see great content can raise to the
top and bring awareness and so I think a
heavy mix of both I'm a big fan of
picking spots strategically that give
you awareness and then build leverage
for you that then eventually you can
monetize in your own world Shawn asks
you are always answering questions about
business brands etc what's the one life
lesson you have learned since becoming a
father Shawn this is a fun question for
me I appreciate it you know I I love
this show because I'm really shooting
straight and in me shooting straight
you're gonna always really realize how
much of a contradiction I really am
you're gonna figure out how much of an
ego I actually have you're gonna figure
out how much humility I actually have
this is gonna go on the ego side I've
always been nurturing I loved HR and the
team and like you guys the community I
have a lot of nurturing DNA you know I'm
a motherly kind of character I also have
an 11 year younger brother that gave me
a test run into fatherhood because my
brother and I have that kind of
relationship especially cuz my dad is
such a workaholic wasn't around as much
no much more for AJ than me I just want
to throw that out there to go to some of
those basketball games which I'm still
jealous about and and in general my
dad's kind of an old-school less
nurturing let's put it that way kind of
guy and so you know when I'm 19 AJ is 8
what that did for me in a lot of ways
was you know it's not the same you know
brother even though as much as I love AJ
it's a different feeling from children I
think you know I think this thing that
it's taught me is the quote I want to
say unconditional love but the truth is
I probably love my parents and siblings
more than
the average person from what I've been
able to gather and so it's taught me
things I knew which is the fear that I
have for any Misha yesterday talking to
me about you know somebody called her
chatterbox and hurt her feelings
hey made me laugh because she's like her
dad and I'm like I remember going my
music teacher in first grade called me
called me a machine mouth or something
like pretty pretty tough anyway
motormouth thank you and so she's going
through that stuff and it was crazy to
me to sit there and feel how much pain I
felt and we're not even in bullying zone
or zit zone or awkward teen yard zone so
it's teaching me that as much as I love
my parents and my siblings and all these
other things the love I have for those
two is is deep and it's a hard core hey
Gary
Tony Brown here from Tony L brown comm
creator of the three V strategy
development and growth I'm just growing
from my faithful Instagram timeline and
I've just seen a post from Instagram
telling me they're gonna start
advertising on the timeline in the UK he
had over six thousand three hundred
comments many of which were saying no no
no you're gonna ruin it provide by
Instagram yep you always say marketers
ruin everything yep what do you thoughts
on that's a couple things show I love it
keep it up sorry and my speech you can
soon speak too soon a couple things
look first of all there's a lot of
different audiences for example 99% of
people that run a Q&A show would not let
allow a question to be aired where the
person spent the first nine percent of
the question promoting himself but I
love the hustle right so there's that
too do you have any Americans I know
you're from the UK the only Americans
said they would leave America and move
to Canada when George Bush got reelected
and then vice versa when Obama got
elected and re-elected how many of my
friends and elitists and rich peeps and
poor peeps and they're gonna move to
Canada if X Y Z the amount of things we
say versus the amount of things we do is
a very
big difference and that's why Instagram
isn't worried about that because I don't
you want to have a real fun little test
go back into that post and then go click
all the people that said bye-bye
Instagram and see how many pictures
they've posted since they commented my
guess a lot more so the question and
answer to your question is so the
answers your question you don't edit
I'm a social scared of die rocks editing
cuz I we added a little more on this
show than we did with my library and I'm
a little scared because I know we're
trying to be efficient and directs
skilled don't take that personal d-roc
but don't edit that crap never edit any
of my mistakes or any of my blood ups
let's start with that if you're editing
just for for time reasons I can respect
that so to answer your question is I
think it's a non-event
of course there's a certain level of
hippies that will go off of that
platform because of that but if
Instagram finds its right rhythm the way
Facebook has I don't see anything really
happening and so I just think it's a
non-event
Johnny asks if the Jets never come up
for sale in your lifetime and another
NFL team does would you buy that team
instead Johnny one of the things I
worried about what this show was
answering questions I don't like to
answer and this is one of them at this
point
I've been flowed with this at this point
my belief is that I would really focus
on the mix and then after that a random
basketball team so it goes Jets Knicks
random basketball team that's your
answer Matt asks how would you promote a
Kickstarter campaign
beyond providing content to raise
awareness and reach funding goals Matt
you know whether I'm bubbling on this no
no I'm stick d-roc I just told you that
I'm not editing on any of my mistakes
Jesus with this guy all you editors are
same want to take out the natural off
them you guys like when I struggle with
my words because it happens so rarely I
think Kickstarter no different than
anything else just cuz you have an ice
thing that you want to do and you
decided to do it on Kickstarter because
that's a platform that has virality back
to the question about medium and
Linkedin that's fine the answer is the
same
Facebook dark posts targeting people
that give a crap about ice cream and
Isis putting out content in blog form
guess contributing I would literally
email every single person that has a
blog of any size or magnitude that plays
in your space I didn't look deeply but
if you're in organic Isis or just Isis
or desserts or ice cream culture I would
map out the 700 people that are in that
space that have blogs or media outlets
and reach out to them and say I'd like
to guess contribute talk about Italian
ices or ice cream or dessert culture in
America or the world generally not
spamming like I want to tell you about
my product it's all about being content
and not being about infomercials too
many of the people watching this show
and the rest of the world when they
think about content they hear Billy Mays
and infomercial when I think about
content
I hear New York Times and scandal get it
it's about making that decision and so
getting distribution putting out good
content and that means guest
contributing Facebook dark posts if
you've got money to drive towards it
reaching out to influencers and chefs
that are in the dessert space to see if
you can JV what I would call business
development hey you know Mario Batali
here's what I can do for you give you
eight percent of my company if you can
get me the spark that starts out my
awareness hey Carla hall I think you're
amazing and you're Southern cuisine I'll
give you five years worth of my product
for free if you give me a little love
how can you give me love a tweets not
enough
so it's bizdev its content creation
that's not infomercial but actual
content and then it's proper internet
marketing which right now to me is creme
de la creme is Facebook dark posts
you've been watching the askgaryvee show
my question of the day for you is very
simple what are you dressing up as for
Halloween you keep asking questions I
will continue to answer them his name
was Michael Jordan and everybody liked
him so much and thought he was so great
but not this guy
I hate Michael Jordan which a Knicks fan
and there's no reason of like why in the
world would I like that dude oh crap
wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social